There are plenty of twists in Spider-Man:
Far From Home, and with everything going on,
there were bound to be a few questions that
got tangled up in the web of illusion.
From cliffhangers to dangling plot threads
to reveals with massive implications for the
future of the MCU, here are the biggest unanswered
questions in Spider-Man: Far From Home.
Spoilers ahead!
The after-credits scene in Spider-Man: Far
From Home drops several bombs in quick succession
and introduces multiple questions about the
future of the MCU.
The scene sees Nick Fury and Maria Hill driving,
when - surprise - they turn into Skrulls.
Well, technically, the Skrulls who were masquerading
as Fury and Hill reveal their true forms.
It turns out that for the entire movie, the
Skrulls Soren and Talos were covering for
the former S.H.I.E.L.D. agents.
Talos then calls someone to report on everything
that just went down in Europe, and we see
that he's talking to none other than Nick
Fury himself, who's on some sort of spaceship
or high-tech base, manned by Skrulls.
But where is he?
Well, while the film doesn't give any concrete
answers, there's one possibility that would
open up a whole new world.
Now that Far From Home has officially closed
the door on MCU Phase Three, we're on the
cusp of a future where the MCU gets a lot
bigger and more cosmic.
A bigger universe means bigger threats, and
what's poor little planet Earth to do in the
face of intergalactic alien invaders?
Easy: Build a big space station to protect
the world from extraterrestrial threats.
Fortunately, someone's already done that:
S.W.O.R.D., or the Sentient World Observation
and Response Department, which debuted in
Astonishing X-Men in 2004 and went on to appear
in issues of Captain Marvel and Secret Invasion,
to name a few comic titles.
It's basically S.H.I.E.L.D. in space, and
it operated as a subdivision of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Is that where Nick Fury was?
There's nothing in the film to confirm it,
but if the post-credits scene of Far From
Home did in fact introduce S.W.O.R.D., it's
kind of a big deal.
See, since it debuted in an X-Men comic, the
film rights to the agency have long been mired
in the whole Fox/Marvel legal rights struggle.
Now that Disney's acquisition of Fox has gone
through, however, that years-long question
of who owns what is a moot point, and the
introduction of S.W.O.R.D. may just mark one
of the first steps in bringing parts of these
different universes together.
Spider-Man: Far From Home's plot is all about
how appearances can be deceiving.
Its central villain, Mysterio, uses complex
holograms to trick the world into thinking
monsters are coming out of the ground, and
he puts that tech to good use in his battles
with Spidey, plunging our hero into a world
where nothing is what it seems.
He's full of tricks.
"And now our magic trick."
"Illusion."
"SILENCE SLAVE"
Paranoia and illusion are all pieces of the
puzzle here, which makes the end-credits reveal
that Maria Hill and Nick Fury were Skrulls
the whole time so perfect.
But that also raises another question with
even bigger ramifications.
Fury has known about, and potentially been
working with, the Skrulls since the '90s,
the decade when Captain Marvel is set.
Despite Carol promising to find them a new
home, some Skulls apparently hung around on
Earth, and Fury clearly has no more qualms
about letting them impersonate important people.
Does this mean we should expect other characters
to turn out to be secret Skrulls?
Hopefully not, but now that the cat's out
of the bag, anything is possible.
Like Tom Holland himself, Peter Parker is
terrible at keeping secrets.
Far From Home marks the second solo Spidey
movie in the MCU, and it also marks the second
solo Spidey movie in the MCU where the main
bad guy knows Peter's real identity.
"I'll kill you and everybody you love."
In the mid-credits scene, Mysterio reveals
Spider-Man's identity to the world, which
is one of Peter's biggest fears.
He just watched Quentin Beck target his closest
friends with murder drones, so he has first-hand
knowledge of the dangers of having your secret
identity exposed.
Now that the whole world knows who he is,
his life is basically open season for any
bad guy who may want a piece of the Spider
pie.
We know from Homecoming that Scorpion's itching
to get back at Spider-Man.
Who else might join the bug hunt?
All his friends and loved ones are in danger,
and even his home is no longer safe.
Clearly, the reveal was intended as a cliffhanger
for a third Spider-Man film, and it's the
kind of question that could lead in any direction.
For a movie about Spider-Man, Far From Home
sure spends a lot of time focusing on Iron
Man.
Specifically, on the vacancy Tony Stark left
behind.
There's a hole in the Avengers roster, a hole
in Peter's heart, and a hole in the world
where the Armored Avenger used to stand.
Peter himself grapples with the question of
whether he is - or at least is supposed to
be - the next Iron Man.
"You gonna be the next Iron Man now?
Well no I don't have time; I'm too busy doing
your job.
Ooooh.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding."
He even gets into the spirit of Tony when
he gets to work building his new suit while
listening to his favorite Led Zeppelin song,
AC/DC's "Back in Black."
But ultimately, there is no answer to be found
in Spider-Man: Far From Home.
The film builds the question to a crescendo,
then leaves it hanging there, presumably for
a future MCU installment.
Darn you and your endless sequels, Marvel!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.